GERBRAND CEDER: --temperature
finite temperature methods
of which you did molecular
dynamics earlier with Professor
Marzari.
So what we're going
to do is sort of
continue that for a bit, showing
you Monte Carlo simulations
and how you can
essentially use it.
And after that is kind of a
series of fairly random topics.
In some cases, clearly we
don't even know what they are.
Even when it says case
study, that really
means that the instructors don't
have a clue yet what they're
going to be teaching about.
Somebody's listening in I think.
OK.
So I want to have a bit of a
discussion on how you calculate
certain properties.
This is a good way
to see the difference
between molecular dynamic
simulation and Monte Carlo.
So in a molecular
dynamic simulation,
one way you calculate
certain properties
is by tracking them over time.
So if you can calculate
a certain property
for a given microscopic state,
for a given configuration,
say the energy--
let's take some simple ones--
or the volume, you calculate
their macroscopic averages,
which are their thermodynamic
qualities, really
as an integral over time.
So there's sort of
two issues with that,
that obviously in that average
you will only include states
that you can reach with the
molecular dynamic simulation.
And so since you simulate
over a finite time,
if there are
excitations, say, which
can determine the average
energy in reality that
occur over a longer
timescale, you
will not sample them
in that average.
The second thing is that
if all you care about
are the average properties
but not the dynamics of how
you go between them,
then sometimes you
can do simpler techniques
than molecular dynamics,
or things that are less
computing intensive.
You can literally just go
and sample those averages.
And so that's
basically what we're
going to talk about this
lecture and the next lecture,
talk about how you
do that sampling.
So if you only care about the
averages but not the dynamics
itself.
You'll see that for
some models of materials
you'll actually need
to do that, because you
won't know the dynamics.
Remember that in
molecular dynamics
you basically assume that
the atoms move with Newton's
equation of motion.
So you know the dynamic.
There will be certain
models for which you have
no idea about the dynamics.
I'll give you an example,
the study an Ising model,
which is a spin model of
magnetic moments sort of being
oriented in space.
In many case you don't
know the spin dynamics.
It's a fairly
complicated problem.
So if all you want to know is
the average magnetic moment,
there's no way of doing
dynamics on the spin.
You'll actually
have to sample them.
So I want to give you one
quick example of a time scale
problem, because
I'm going to use
this example throughout
the lecture to illustrate
how we use Monte Carlo.
Here's a binary mixture,
sort of green and blue atoms.
You may want to know the
average energy of that system.
So in any given
configuration, let's
say you have an energy
method to calculate
the energy of that system.
So at high temperature
the atoms will simply
sort of hop around and give
you some average energy.
So I want to give you an
idea of what you need--
do you mind passing around--
Thank you.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE]---- of
what kind of timescale you need
to get that average right.
Thanks.
And you saw, from Professor
Marzari's last lecture,
the relation between
the diffusion
constant and the root
mean square displacement.
Essentially, the root mean
square displacement scales
linear with the
diffusion constant,
where d is the dimensionality
of the system--
so in this case 2--
and so D is the
diffusion constant.
OK.
To get an idea of the kind
of hopping rate you need,
you can assume for a second
that the atoms do a random walk.
If you do a random
walk, then the root
mean square
displacement you take
is the number of
jumps you take--
N times the jump
distance squared.
You may remember that
for a random walk.
So that means that
now we know we
can relate the jump rate, the
N dt to the diffusion constant.
And I'll call the N dt, which
is the jump rate, gamma.
So if you know how long
your simulation can last,
you sort of know what
jump you need to see
atoms jump in that simulation.
So you can relate that to--
excuse me-- the
diffusivity you need.
And let me sort of do
that on the next page.
OK.
We know that the jump rate
is some vibrational frequency
times a success factor.
When atoms have to
jump over a barrier,
if Ea is the activation
barrier, we essentially
assume that they attempt with
some vibrational frequency,
which is, you could say, the
frequency with which they
sort of try to go up the
hill times the success rate.
And the success rate is
that Boltzmann factor,
the exponential
minus Ea over kT.
If you assume that the
vibrational frequencies
of the order of 10 to the
13 Hertz, which typically we
are, anywhere from 10
to 12, 10 to the 14,
let's say you want to get a
jump rate of 10 to the 10 hertz.
Why would we want
10 to the 10 12?
So 10 to the 10, that's one
jump or 100 picoseconds.
Is that right?
Yeah.
0.1 jump for 0.1 nanoseconds.
So if you did a
10-nanosecond simulation,
you'd have about
100 jumps per atom.
Which would be reasonable
for some equilibration,
but in many cases
still not enough.
OK.
This is sort of a reasonable
jump rate to expect.
That means that your success
rate, your Boltzmann factor,
has to be greater than
10 to the minus 3.
So 1 out of 1,000 times the atom
has to jump across the barrier.
So you can deduce from that what
the activation energy should
be.
Essentially, the
activation energy
should be about less than 7 kT.
And then you'll see
jumps of the order
of once per 100 picoseconds.
And just to put these
numbers in your head,
because they're sort of
important to remember,
at 300 k, 7 kT is 180
millielectronvolt--
that's a low barrier.
If you simulate
at 1,000 degrees,
you can do much higher barriers.
Now, 7 kT is about
600 millielectronvolt.
Now you're starting to be in
the range of typical to low
barriers in solids.
Of course, in
liquids you'll have
much, much faster transport.
So in liquids you'll
have no problem.
If you do the liquid
at 1,000 degrees,
you'll have a tremendous
amount of hopping.
Solid barriers are anywhere
typically from 0.5 to 2
electronvolt. So to put--
it's kind of important, I think,
that you kind of get an idea
of these scales that you need.
And so, like I said
in the beginning,
if the average is
all you care about,
it may be better to simply
do a sampling technique.
And that's essentially
what Monte Carlo is.
Monte Carlo is often mistaken
for another form of dynamics,
but it is really nothing
more than a sampling method.
So now remember
what the issue is.
So if you want to get a sample--
this is in any
statistical methods--
there are two things
you have to decide,
which population
you sample from--
how do you set constraints
on the population of states
that you sample from--
and with what probability
do you sample them,
or should you sample them
unbiased for example.
So there are two issues
that always come up
with sampling, the
probability or the rate
with which you sample a
particular state and the group
of states, the constraints
on the states, over which you
sample.
So before I get
into that, I want
to briefly review the
statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics
altogether in 15 minutes.
And I know a lot of
you have seen that.
Some of you have not
seen that so much.
I sort of want to try to
put us all on the same page.
You know, I find when I
see Monte Carlo simulation
that people do, the biggest
mistake people always
make is at the
outset it has nothing
to do with the technical
implications of Monte Carlo,
it's defining the
boundary conditions,
which is essentially defining
the constraints on the states
you sample.
Those constraints come from
the thermodynamic boundary
conditions you impose
on your system.
I have sometimes
really funny stories.
I've seen discussions at
meetings where people argue
strongly back and
forth about problems,
and all it is a misdefining of
their thermodynamic boundary
conditions.
About two years ago,
I was at a meeting
where people had enormous
discussions about where
hydrogen sits on palladium.
Palladium is a pretty
good hydrogen absorber,
and people would
argue back and forth.
It sits on the surface--
and somebody says, no, it's at
subsurface, layer subsurface.
All that is-- it
actually can sit both,
it's just a matter
of thermodynamics.
If your hydrogen chemical
potential, your external field,
is high enough, it
sits everywhere.
Period.
And so thinking about your
thermodynamic boundary
conditions before you make any
conclusions is quite important.
So for those of you--
let me just remind
you of the relation
between the thermodynamic
boundary conditions
and the statistical ensemble.
The statistical
ensemble is essentially
the group of states
over which you sample.
So we're always going
to make the relation
between a microscopic ensemble--
so this is the group of
states for which you sample.
You could think of it, it's
the boundary conditions
on the states over
which you sample--
should you sample any
configuration, should you
constrain them--
and the macroscopic
thermodynamics.
And the relation here is made
between statistical mechanics.
In the end, it's very easy.
Any fixed thermodynamic
variable--
I'll come to that in the
second, what they are--
sets a constraint on
how you can sample.
And more particularly,
the constraints
come from what are called
the extensive thermodynamic
variables.
So remember, extensive
thermodynamic variables
are things at scale with
size, things like volume,
number of atoms of a given type.
And intensive variables
are the conjugates.
Those are the ones that don't
scale that size-- temperature,
pressure, chemical potential.
You'll see in a second that
the probability with which you
sample depends on the
relevant Hamiltonian,
and the macroscopic
pound counterpart of that
is a free energy function.
So a Hamiltonian in
microscopic space
will correspond to a free energy
function in macroscopic space.
OK.
So here's all I'm going to say
about thermal is sort of one
slide that I think represents
pretty much all you need
to know for doing sampling.
In thermodynamics
variables appear in groups,
what we call conjugate pairs.
And one way you can
see how they belong,
it's the couples that appear
together in the first law.
First law tells
you, essentially,
that the change of
internal energy of a system
is the net energy flow
in or out of that system.
And you can write that from
different contributions.
TdS you could think
of as the heat flow,
pdV is the mechanical
or volume work done,
mu dN as the chemical work.
So if u is the
chemical potential,
N is the number of
atoms of a given type.
So remember, these
are conjugate pairs.
S is an extensive, T is an
intensive, V is an extensive,
p is an intensive, N is an
extensive, mu is an intensive.
Essentially, the
rule is very simple.
To define your
boundary conditions,
you always need to specify
one out of each pair.
So you need to
say whether you're
at constant entropy or
constant temperature,
whether you're at constant
pressure or constant volume,
chemical potential
or constant number of particles.
You could not leave
one unspecified.
If you do that, you're
actually always making
an implicit assumption.
OK.
If you have a closed box and
nothing can go in and out,
you're obviously under
constant number of particles.
A really classic
mistake is simulating
on the constant
number of particles,
when you're really, in reality,
under constant chemical field.
Surfaces are a really
good example of that.
If you study a surface, you will
often study it in simulation
under constant
number of particles.
It's sort of the
obvious thing to do.
But real surfaces are
actually equilibrated
with their environment.
So they're under constant
chemical potential field
of the environment or under
constant chemical potential
from their bulk.
And in some cases
that doesn't matter.
But in other cases
that actually will.
So the number of atoms
on a surface can change.
In statistical mechanics,
we tend to not use this
formulation of the first
law, but we tend interchange
the role of the internal energy
and the entropy literally
by moving this to the left-hand
side and dividing by T--
so riding the differential
of the entropy instead.
And you'll see in a
second that that's
a much more useful
thermodynamic notation
to correlate to
statistical mechanics.
So this is called the
entropy formulation.
And in the entropy
formulation, U and 1 over T
are conjugate variables.
U is the extensive, 1
over T is the intensive,
V is the the extensive, p
over T is the extensive.
I hope you can see
this is just a rewrite
of the standard first law.
OK.
So how do the thermodynamic
boundary conditions
relate to the ensemble's
over which you average?
The ensembles are determined
by the extensive variables
you keep constant.
So if you think about, if
you go back for a second
the previous slide,
the simplest is
that you keep the energy,
the volume, the number
of particles, constant.
That's all the
extensive variables.
All the extensive
variables, that's
the ensemble at constant energy,
volume, number of particles.
That's what's called the
microcanonical ensemble.
A realization of that would
be if you did a system
in a box, Newtonian dynamics.
If it's in a closed box,
the number of particles
can't change, the
volume is fixed.
And if you do Newtonian
dynamics, the energy is fixed.
So the basic form of molecular
dynamics, you could say,
goes through a
microcanonical ensemble.
If you start thermostating your
energy to fix the temperature,
then you go out of the
microcanonical ensemble.
So if you release the
constraint of fixed energy,
then you have to control
the average energy.
And you do that with
the temperature.
Then you end up in what's
called a canonical ensemble.
If you release the constraint
of fixed number of particles,
again, then you have
to take into account
the field that sets your
average number of particles.
So then you have an
ensemble with T, V, and mu.
That's called a grand
canonical ensemble.
You can keep on making
other ensembles by switching
in intensive variables
for extensive,
it's just that we
run out of names.
These are three classic names--
microcanonical, canonical,
and grand canonical.
After that, we sort of have
no names for them anymore,
but they do exist.
OK.
So that defines the states
from which you should sample.
The question is, now,
how do you sample?
Well, first I'm going to tell
you how you should sample,
and then I'll tell you how
you really sample in practice.
You should sample with
the correct probability.
And the probability of
a state in an ensemble
is proportional to the
exponential of minus beta,
the Hamiltonian--
again, remember,
beta is 1 over kT--
and then normalized
by the sum of that
over all the states, which is
called the partition function,
PrZ.
And the free energy
is essentially the log
of that partition function.
Now, what should
that Hamiltonian be?
You've probably seen this kind
of probability function a lot
already when you
substitute in the energy.
In more general
terms, that should
be the relevant
microscopic Hamiltonian,
and it should include
all the things that
can fluctuate in your system.
Typically, the way
I sort of remember
what goes into
Hamiltonian, you think
of your thermodynamic
boundary conditions,
you take the relevant Legendre
transform of your entropy,
and it's essentially
those pieces
that go in your Hamiltonian.
For example, if you work
at fixed N, V, and T,
the relevant free energy is
the Helmholtz free energy,
which is S minus E over
T. This is the part that
goes into your Hamiltonian.
It's whatever is the Legendre
transform part of the entropy.
And that's what you see.
In a canonical ensemble,
you weigh states
with the exponential of
minus beta the energy.
That's the one you're used to.
But let's say you go to a
grand canonical ensemble.
So now you're at fixed
chemical potential
so the number of
states can fluctuate.
So now the relevant
thermodynamic potential,
the relevant Legendre
transform of the entropy
has a minus E over T and
a plus mu over T in it.
So that's essentially
the part that
appears in your Hamiltonian.
So now you weigh
with minus beta times
the energy minus mu N. Just sort
of think of that as a Legendre
transform Hamiltonian almost.
And if you were to simulate
that constant pressure ,
you would have a P over T times
V term in your Hamiltonian.
If you sort think about
it, it makes sense
that you need these terms
in your Hamiltonian.
Because if they don't
appear in your Hamiltonian,
you have no way of controlling
the number of particles.
OK.
It's sort of going backwards.
So this is here
sort of the summary.
The macroscopic
boundary conditions
are set by the constant
extensive thermodynamic
variables.
That in turn defines
the relevant ensemble
and the probability which
you sample over an ensemble.
And when you do
that all correctly,
you can get the
averages of properties,
such as the energy
and the volume
with those probabilities.
OK.
Just one brief aside--
there's an implicit
assumption you
make in here, which is common
to statistical mechanics.
We've essentially said that
following a system in time
will give the same averages
then sampling over its ensemble.
The assumption in
there is that when
you follow a system in time,
it will reach essentially
all the states in its ensemble.
Or, maybe simpler said, it will
reach all the states it can--
it will reach all the states
that are within the boundary
conditions.
So if you put--
think about this.
What you're really
saying is if you
put a system in a box,
fixed number of particle,
say, at constant temperature,
not constant energy,
you're essentially saying
that that system will,
if you wait long enough, reach
any possible configuration
of atoms.
Because that's the one that will
be allowed in your ensemble.
And that's called the
ergodicity principle.
The ergodicity principle says
that if you wait long enough
a system will reach,
finally, all its states .
Because if you know that it's
going to reach all its states
and you know the
probability of them,
then you can just sum over it.
And that's what you do
in statistical mechanics,
rather than doing
the full dynamics.
This is where we usually
have to give you the caveat--
the lawyer's caveat-- that
not all systems are ergodic.
Most practical ones are.
The examples that are often
given as non-ergodic system
are a bit fake.
And one that I like to bring
up is the harmonic oscillator.
If you think of a
harmonic oscillator,
think of something,
a mass, that is
in contact with a rigid
object to a spring.
If you think that
the two coordinates--
what are the two
coordinates of this system?
Well, there's a position
coordinate, where this mass is,
and there's a
velocity coordinate.
Well, because it's a
harmonic oscillator,
the two are actually correlated.
So if you think of the phase
pace of the system as--
here's the spatial coordinate,
here's the velocity coordinate.
The system actually
goes through an ellipse.
It actually never goes to states
like this and this and this.
So people say the harmonic
oscillator is not ergodic.
I'd say it's not ergodic because
you took a stupid phase space.
It's because you essentially
said that the system has
to coordinates.
So in a two-dimensional
space, it's not ergodic.
In a one-dimensional
space, it is ergodic.
This system has
only one coordinate.
That's its normal mode.
So if you write it in the
normal mode, it is ergodic.
In one dimension, it is ergodic.
So along that trajectory, if
you say that's your phase space,
the system is ergodic.
So it's a bit of a
matter of definition.
In the obvious coordinate
space, this one is not ergodic.
And then there are systems
that for practical reasons
are essentially non-ergodic.
They just never get there going
through all their phase spaces.
Glasses are really difficult
to do thermodynamics on,
to integrate phase space
over, because you really
don't know over what
region to integrate.
If I give you atoms--
I say, give me the
free energy of a glass.
Really, when you
think about it, you
don't know what ensemble
to integrate over.
Because if you say,
well, what is a glass?
Well, it's sort of random.
So can I just average over
all the possible positions
in the box?
Then I'm actually getting
the free energy of a liquid.
The glass actually never samples
all the possible positions.
So you could argue that it's
a liquid that's not ergodic.
And if you sort of
think of it, it's
a liquid that's frozen [? in. ?]
OK.
So finally we're going to get
to the Monte Carlo simulation.
Before that, I want to
introduce one toy model.
And you'll see the relation
with the mixing problem.
And that's the
Ising model, which
is essentially a spin model.
So we have lots of sites.
At every site we can have
an up spin or a down spin.
So there's only a binary
variable at every site.
We'll mark that with a plus
1 or minus 1-- say plus 1
for up and minus 1 for down.
And so the simplest
Hamiltonian or energy function
you can write for
this system is one
that counts the nearest
neighbor bonds and associates
some interaction with them.
So I and J are only nearest
neighbors in this model.
So let's say if J
is positive, then,
since there's a
minus sign here, you
will want to make this positive
so you'll get a ferromagnet.
That means if you have
a plus 1 somewhere,
you'll want a plus 1 next
to it to get flow energy.
If J is negative, you will want
the spin product sigma I sigma
J to be negative.
That means if you
you have a plus spin,
you'll want a negative
spin next to it.
So you have antiferromagnet.
So it's the simplest possible
magnetic model you can make.
And that was Ising's PhD thesis.
And his advisors
really hated it.
His advisor was so mad at
him for that PhD thesis
that Ising left science and
he became a businessman.
So he never knew he
became famous later on.
But what you're going to
see is that the Ising model
is sort of a conduit.
It's a model I will use
for any two-state system.
So any time you
have a model where
there's sort of two
possibilities on the lattice
side, we'll use this model.
Because I call it
a magnetic spin.
I mean, you could
call it low fat,
high fat cheese, whatever--
any time you have two states.
So we're going to use it for
binary alloys, for example.
If we have a mixture of
A and B on a lattice,
you could say the plus 1
is A, the minus 1 is B.
So that's why it is
such a useful model.
OK.
So how would you sample
a model like that?
Well, let me first
tell you a little bit
about where the ideas of
sampling and Monte Carlo
sampling came from.
It's typically
credited to the people
at Los Alamos, Monte Carlo
samples, who built the ENIAC
computer, which is
essentially, I think,
the first computer or one of the
first computers that was built.
One of these things
with vacuum tubes,
and you could calculate
for 10 seconds
and then one of the
tubes would break.
And then you'd replace the
tube and calculate another 10
seconds.
But I believe idea of
Monte Carlo sampling really
goes back to Fermi.
People before that sort of
had sampling ideas already.
They sort of knew how to
use sampling for things that
were difficult to integrate.
And the first example
that I thought is known is
by the Comte de Buffon-- which
I think is a beautiful name.,
buffon is like--
who thought of this as a method
for integrating functions.
And the idea is very
simple, that if you
have this function that
you can't integrate,
or maybe it's
numerically defined,
a really simple way to
integrate is to draw a box
and throw darts in that box.
Randomly take
points in that box,
and you'll hit here once in
a while, and here, and here,
and here.
And if you think about it, if
you track the number of times
that you're below
the curve, that's
telling you something about
that integral under the curve.
Because the number of times
below the curve is the integral
divided by the total area.
So the area of the
square is the total area,
and the integral is
a fraction of that.
And so that fraction
is the probability
that you hit below the curve.
So by just knowing how many
times you're below the curve,
you have a reasonable
estimate of the integral.
And if you do this
with a lot of points,
you'll get a good
approximation to the integral.
This is how kids in
school learn to integrate.
My daughter's in third
grade, and the way
they learn to integrate is
by putting grids on this
and counting how many grid
points are below the curve.
Which you could say is a
sampling method-- it's just
not a random sampling methods.
You use sample with a fixed grid
rather than with a random grid.
So I was going to give
you an assignment.
This is one of these
assignments for when you're
sitting in a boring lecture--
which is not this one, but
another boring lecture--
or you're sitting on an
airplane and they hold you
for two hours on the tarmac
with nowhere to go and no food.
You should try to determine pi.
And here's a way
of determining pi.
You know that pi
essentially relates
to the ratio of the
area of a circle divided
by the area of the square
that's circumscribed.
Because this area
here, if you just
take, say, a quadrant of this,
is 1 over 4 pi r squared.
And the area of the
square is r squared.
So the ratio of those
two is 1/4 times pi.
So if you throw darts randomly
at this thing, if you count
the fraction of the times
you're within the circle divided
by the total number of points,
you'll get an estimate for pi.
So you should try
this, like throw darts.
You can't bring darts anymore
in an airplane unfortunately,
so you'll have to kind of
like hold your pen randomly.
And you should see once
how quickly or slowly you
actually approach pi.
You get the first few
digits pretty quickly
actually-- not so bad.
But then, after that, of
course, it goes really slowly.
Because, essentially,
to get the third digit,
you're going to have to
almost do 1,000 points.
But when you're bored,
it's not a bad thing to do.
So let's talk more
about sampling.
There are essentially
many ways of sampling,
but I'm going to give
you two extremes.
One is called simple sampling.
One is called
importance sampling.
Later, in one of
the later lectures,
I'll sort of show you that
you could kind of do anything
in between as well.
So what is simple sampling?
It's kind of what these
previous methods were.
You would randomly pick
points in your phase space.
So if you randomly pick points,
that means now states of atoms
or whatever the states
of your system are,
you have to weigh them with
the correct probability.
But you could do that.
So you could
randomly pick states.
Let's say the state is new here.
The property in the
state is A. So the way
you get the average
of A is by weighing
that A with the
probability of that state.
And we know how to
calculate the probability.
Probability we know
is proportional
to that exponential of minus
beta of the Hamiltonian.
What I don't know is
the partition function
that I have to normalize with.
But what I can do
is after I sampled
a bunch of states
I can literally
define an approximation
to my partition function
as the sum of that exponential
over all the states that I've
sampled [INAUDIBLE].
And I need that, because
I need to normalize
my probabilities to 1.
Simple sampling, it's called
simple because, as I said,
economists use it.
That was a joke, but, you know.
It works for small spaces--
small phase spaces.
It does not work at all
for materials for a reason
I'll tell you in a second.
And you think that's obvious.
Did you think that was obvious
that simple sampling does not
work for materials?
Who thought that was obvious?
Nobody.
So it's not obvious.
Good.
Because otherwise, it
was a trick question.
I'll show you in a second
that it's not obvious.
But why does it not work?
You essentially,
with simple sampling,
pick states in proportion
to their degeneracy.
So if you think of
your spin model,
let's say you're spinning
at a low temperature
where this thing wants to
be a ferromagnet with all
the spins aligned.
How would you pick spins?
Well, if you pick
them randomly, you
would never end up with a
ferromagnetic configuration.
Because you picked the spin
here up, here down, here up,
here down.
So you would sample a lot
of states in the phase space
but never the relevant one.
OK.
And typically you pick
states with higher entropy.
And you know that, because
the entropy is essentially
the log of the multiplicity.
The entropy at a given
energy is the log
of the number of
states of that energy.
So remember, if you
do simple sampling,
you're going to pick states
proportional to omega.
So you're always going to
pick states with high energy,
because we know that d log dE is
1 over kT is a positive number.
So that means the number of
states with a given energy
is an increasing
function of energy.
So that means that
if you simple sample
you're almost never
going to pick down here,
because there are
almost no states.
You're always going
to pick up here,
because there are a
lot of states there.
See the parallel with
your spin model is--
see, these are the
ferromagnetic states.
You have low energy,
everything's nicely lined up.
These are all the random
states, the paramagnetic states.
In reality, your system
lives somewhere in between.
At some temperature it
has some average energy,
and then it has a fluctuation
of energy around it.
So your real system
kind of samples these
states, and you're
always hanging out here--
you're always sampling
the wrong thing.
If you had said that this was
obvious that it wouldn't work,
I would have thrown this at you.
Here's a paper from
a famous physicist
that I respect very well,
but he was so wrong.
This was somebody
who's been great
in density functional theory.
He has done beautiful work
in it and at some point tried
to do a phase diagram.
And realize, of
course, I blanked out
the name out of respect.
But of course you
could find out.
They were really good at
doing quantum mechanics
and getting energies of states.
And they wanted to
get free energies now
at finite temperature.
This was on the
aluminum lithium system.
I mean this is 1988.
This was like if there was
any heydays ever of aluminum
lithium, this was it.
Everybody was working
on aluminum lithium,
because everybody thought that
was the alloy of the future.
Because lithium is
the lightest metal.
It's the lightest solid
in the periodic table.
So any atom you can
replace by lithium
will make your alloys lighter.
So that was a big dream.
You could make really light
airplanes and whatever.
And [INAUDIBLE] built
anomalous capacity
for making aluminum
lithium alloys, et cetera,
and it never panned out.
Turned out you couldn't
weld them very well,
and they have really
bad fatigue resistance.
So you really don't want to
make an airplane out of them.
Ironically, they make the
doors of airplanes out of them.
I never know how to
figure that one out.
And the seat frames,
there's aluminum.
But the seat is supported on
is out of aluminum lithium.
But the doors always scares
me, when I sit by the door
and I know this is
aluminum lithium, which
has poor fatigue
resistance and very poor
welding characteristics.
But anyway, everybody
worked on aluminum lithium.
And so these guys were good
at doing quantum mechanics.
So how did they get
the phase diagram?
That they actually took a box
of atoms and randomly made up
configurations and then
calculated the energy along
with quantum mechanics.
So this was essentially
simple sampling.
And then they summed that and
got the partition function.
If you have the
partition functioning,
you have the free energy.
And this was the phase diagram
that came out to the right.
It sort of violates all
kinds of phase rules,
and it's completely wrong.
And so it's not that
obvious that simple sampling
doesn't work, because even
the best people have done it.
I like this example.
This comes out of a great book.
This is the book
by Franklin Smith.
And I'll show you a list
of references at the end.
This is a great
book on Monte Carlo
if you want to delve
deeper into it.
They have this great
analogy of simple sample
versus importance sampling.
The question is, how do you
measure the average depth
of the Nile River?
And simple sampling
is essentially, well,
you know the Nile is in Africa,
so you just walk around Africa
with a dipstick and you sort of
measure how deep the Nile is.
So of course, most of the
time you're not in the Nile,
so you get a lot of zeros.
So what's a smarter
way to do it?
Well, a smarter ways
to first find the Nile.
That's putting a
bias on your sample.
You really want to
get to the Nile.
And then once
you're in the Nile,
you want to stay in the Nile.
So that means you still want to
have some amount of randomness
to walk around in the
Nile, otherwise you're
not getting the average
depth of the Nile.
But you want to be
biased, so you stay in it.
And that's the idea of
importance sampling.
Remember, what is
importance sampling?
You want to sample
the important states.
Those are the ones
with low energy.
If you want to set up a
thermodynamically-relevant
ensemble, obviously you
know that your system
spends most of its time in
the states with low energy
and then fluctuates around it.
So you want to get to the low
energy and stay around it.
So you want a sample
with bias and then
correct your probabilities
for that bias.
That's the whole idea.
OK.
So here's the idea of
importance sampling.
Remember, in a random
sample, you pick randomly.
And to average a
property, you weigh
the property in each state
with the correct probability.
Now, if you think about
it, maybe the best
sample we could make--
couldn't we sample right
away with that probability?
So could we sample with
a probability that's
directly proportional to the
real probability the state
should have in the ensemble?
So if you do that, if you
could sample these states
with the propr probability,
then their average is just
determined by summing
them, by a trivial average.
So does everybody
see the difference?
In simple sampling, you
randomly pick things.
In importance sampling,
you right away
try to shoot for getting them
with the proper probability
so the low energy state's a
lot more than the high energy
state.
Keep that in mind.
There will be properties
where you need the high energy
states.
And then you're going to have
to adjust your Monte Carlo
sampling algorithm to go there.
Because in some cases
maybe some properties
are determined by extreme
in your distribution.
Maybe when it gets
to a certain energy
your system does
something weird.
If you want to
see that, then you
should bias your
system towards there.
But if we're interested in
just thermodynamic behavior,
we want to sample around
the energy minimum.
So there are various
ways that you
can construct the
probability-weighted sample.
A common way is what's called
a metropolis algorithm.
And this is the one
we'll use pretty much
exclusively in the [INAUDIBLE].
And the idea is
that you construct
what's called a Markov
chain, which is really
just a sequence of states,
where, over a long time, if you
do it long enough,
you visit each state
with the proper probability.
So I'm going to
define two quantities,
and then I'm going to tell you
what rules they should obey.
So obviously you have to
start with some state.
Well, in a metropolis
algorithm you
can pick that state randomly.
So I call that state i.
Then you have to pick a
new state called j from i.
And the rate at which
we pick that state
I call omega 0 i to j.
But you don't always
accept that state.
You accept that with some
probability p i going to j.
So the total transfer rate, how
many times you pick j from i,
and put it in the Markov
chain is determined
by the product of these two.
It's times you actually pick
it as a possible transfer
state times the success
rate in getting there.
That's p i j.
The two conditions that
a metropolis algorithm
has to satisfy are
typically these two.
The first one isn't
actually a real condition,
it's just sort of a
practical one to work with.
Usually people look
for what's called equal
a priori probabilities.
What that means is that the
rate at which you pick j froim i
should be the same as the rate
at which you pick i from j.
That's actually not
absolutely necessary.
But if you don't satisfy this,
you have to correct later on.
And we'll do that two
lectures from now-- we'll
give you an example of that.
But it's easiest to work with
equal a priori probabilities.
In most this is a
condition that's
amazingly easily satisfied.
You'll see that.
Next lecture, we'll do some
examples of complicated Monte
Carlo moves, and it's
hard to violate this one.
You have to work on it.
But it does happen.
The more important one is
what's called detailed balance.
Detailed balance is that the
rate at which you actually
transfer from i to jay and
the rate at which you transfer
from j to i has to be inversely
proportional to the probability
that you're in
the initial state.
So essentially the
rate at which you
go from i to j over the rate
at which you go from j to i
has to equal p j over p i, or
these are the probabilities
that you are in that state.
It's actually fairly
easy to convince yourself
that if that's true
you're going to end up
with a correct
probability distribution.
I mean, think about it.
If you look at this carefully,
what is this really saying?
That if you were doing a lot
of samplings in parallel,
this gives you a steady
state distribution of states.
Because if you look
at the left-hand side
of the green box, that's
the number of times
you're going out if i into j.
Because it's the probability
that you're in i times
the rate at which
you transfer to j.
And the right-hand
side is the probability
at the rate at which
you go from j to i.
Which is, first of all,
you have to be in j--
otherwise you can't
go from j to i--
times the rate W j i, the rate
at which you go from j to i.
So when these two are
equal, you sort of
have a net zero flow
of probability density.
So you have a steady
state distribution.
If this holds for all
pair of states i j,
your probability distribution
isn't changing anymore.
So you end up with a
steady state distribution.
You can be fairly
creative about how
you make metropolis algorithms.
But here's a very simple
one, which you'll often see
a lot in a Monte Carlo codes.
So you first have to design some
pick rate, some rate at which
you choose new states for i.
So that's omega 0.
So you have to
have some mechanism
for picking potential moves.
So omega 0 i to j.
And then you have to have
an acceptance criteria.
And a typical
acceptance criteria
is that you accept the
probability from i to j is 1.
That means you definitely accept
when the energy goes down--
so when the new state
has lower energy than i,
than the previous state.
And if the new state has higher
energy than the initial state,
then you accept with
a Boltzmann factor.
So then you accept with
a certain probability.
You can easily show that this
satisfies detailed balance.
Because if you-- let's see if
I can squeeze this in here.
Detailed balances that
essentially p i p i to j
has to equal p j
p j to I. Well p i
is the exponential of minus beta
i over the partition function.
p i to J, let's assume that i is
the state with low energy is 1.
That has to equal p j,
which is the exponential.
Sorry for my poor writing here.
This pen is displaced
from where I see it.
This is exponential
minus beta E j over z,
times p i j, which
is the exponential.
I'm going to write
it below here.
The exponential of
minus beta Ei minus Ej.
This Ej cancels with
this one, and so you
get that the exponential
is minus beta Ei equals
the exponential minus beta Ei.
So this set of transfer rates
satisfies detailed balance
in an almost trivial way.
So how would you
practically implement
a metropolis algorithm
for sampling phase space?
You would start with some
configuration you would choose
a perturbation of the system.
So that's essentially
determine your mechanism
for picking omega 0 i j.
You compute the energy
for that perturbation.
If the change is negative,
you accept the perturbation.
If it's positive, you accept
it with some probability.
And then you go on and you
choose the next perturbation.
And so you essentially
cycle this.
So you build up a
sequence of states.
This is your sample.
This must be a Pentium 286.
It's checking the equations.
That's-- OK.
So what you will get
then is some property
as a function of sample
size or sampling,
which is often called
Monte Carlo time.
Which is very confusing,
because this is not
a dynamical trajectory.
You could think of it as a
trajectory through phase space,
but there's nothing
here that says that it's
a dynamical trajectory.
I'm going to later
confuse you even more
and talk about what's called
kinetic Monte Carlo, which
is a way of mimicking
dynamics with Monte Carlo.
But standard Monte
Carlo simply has
nothing to do with kinetics.
It's an efficient way
to sample phase space.
So you'll go through
some property,
and then you just essentially
track the average.
Typically what people
do is they often,
just for practical
consideration,
cut off the first
part and remove it.
Because, remember, you
started with a random state.
You may be very far away
from the low energy state.
And so by cutting that off,
the first part, you often
get a much faster
relaxation of the average.
Because the initial
state may have
really very high energy and
thereby some weird property.
And so you only start
sampling after the system has
relaxed towards the minimum.
So you often talk about,
in Monte Carlo, people
using a certain amount
of equilibration passes
and after a certain
amount of sampling passes.
And you only average
over the sampling pass.
So let's go through this for
the very simple magnetic model.
How will you do it in a magnetic
model, in a simple Ising model?
You could randomly
initialize the spin.
You could start with that.
You could also start with a
ferromagnetic configuration.
The closer you start to
your equilibrium state,
the faster this is going to go.
An obvious perturbation
is you pick a spin
and you flip it over.
So if it was up,
you make it down.
If it was down, you make it up.
Calculate the energy
for perturbation.
If it goes down, you accept it.
If it doesn't, you accept
it with a certain Boltzman
probability and you go back.
And as you can see, you
can do this very fast.
If you think of computer
code now, how you write this,
these are trivial operations.
You have to calculate
a random number
to randomly pick a
spin in the lattice,
or two if it's a
two dimensional.
You have to compute the
energy, but your Hamiltonian
is just like j sigma i sigma j.
That goes really fast.
It's like multiplying
a few numbers.
And then you have to compute
that exponential also.
So you can cycle this through
literally millions of times
per second on a modern computer.
Even on a very basic
computer, if you
did just this
two-dimensional Ising model,
if you coded it well, you
could do probably 50 million
of these per second.
So that's how fast you can
sample through your ensemble.
So here's what comes out.
Here's real output.
So this is the 2D square
lattice model I showed you.
The temperature is in
units of j over k--
so the interaction constant
or the Boltzmann constant.
So kT over j equals 2, that's
actually below the period
temperature of this model.
So this is a
ferromagnetic model.
And so if you heat it up,
it would go paramagnetic
at some point.
This is still below that
temperature, but it's not far.
The transition temperature
would be about 2.23
or something like that,
2.24 in this model.
So you're below the paramagnetic
transition temperature,
but not much.
So I started it up
randomly I think.
And so the energy
is sort of high.
It kind of fluctuates
for a while
and then starts going down.
And here it seems to
have relaxed fairly well,
and then it just kind of
fluctuates around the average.
And you average this and
you'd get the energy.
If you want to know
the magnetization,
well, you would keep track
of the magnetization, which
is sort of the difference
between how much up spin
do I have and how much
down spin do I have.
You track that, and
this is that quantity
as a function of
temperature, and see
it's clearly ferromagnetic.
You have preferred up spin.
It slowly goes down
with temperature.
And then this is the
transition temperature.
It's the paramagnetic
transition temperature,
beautiful second-order
transition.
So just to give an idea,
doing this with Monte Carlo
is a one-page code without
the bells and whistles.
And it runs before you blink.
I mean, it's so fast that
you would sample this.
OK.
How do you detect
phase transitions?
This is sort of a critical
issue in any simulation method
to be honest.
Whether you do Monte Carlo
or molecular dynamics,
it's one thing to
look at the atoms,
and it's another thing to figure
out exactly what they're doing.
You may have seen that
if you try to do things
like melting with
molecular dynamics,
it's not trivial to exactly
find where the atoms melt.
Because what do you do?
You just stare at them.
But it seems kind of a fairly
random decision about--
let's say I gave you
this lattice model,
and I asked you, where
does it become disordered?
Where is the paramagnetic
transition temperature?
You could just
stare at the spins.
But I'll tell you, when you're
close to that transition,
just below and just above,
it looks pretty similar.
And one is still the
ferromagnetic phase.
The other one's the
antiferromagnetic phase.
So you need a more
systematic way
of looking at phase transitions.
And the beauty is
you can do that
through the thermodynamic
quantities you sampled.
If you sample the
energy, you typically
use the fact that the
energy is discontinuous
at first-order transitions.
It's not so at
second-order transitions.
If you work at constant
chemical potential-- and I'll
come to that later.
It's often a useful thing
to do in Monte Carlo.
it tends to equilibrate faster--
you will have concentration
discontinuities
at first-order transition.
Another thing to usually
track is the heat capacity
of the system.
The heat capacity is the
fluctuation of the energy.
If you go back--
can I go back?
The heat capacity is
essentially a measure
of how much you fluctuate
around the average.
It's your sigma squared.
So the heat capacity is
defined as the fluctuation
of the energy-- so E
squared average minus E
average squared.
That tends to show singularities
at second-order transitions.
But it's even useful often to
spot first-order transitions,
even though it's a
little harder to.
I'll show you a lot of sort
of case studies and examples
on more complicated
systems later on.
But for example, here's
the heat capacity
of that 2D model as a function
of normalized temperature.
So notice how the heat
capacity the transition
is here of course,
about 2.24 or so.
[INAUDIBLE] has a
beautiful singularity.
This is actually a logarithmic
divergence to infinity.
So you can't miss
this transition.
Even if you tried,
you wouldn't miss it.
There's a great Java
program on the web that
does two-dimensional
lattice files
if you want to play with it.
And you can literally type in
temperatures and interaction
strength, and it just
simulates on the screen for you
and plots like
thermodynamic quantities.
Pretty cool.
OK.
So in the last
bit of time I want
to go through some variants
of this lattice model, how
we use it for other fields.
And then, in the next
lecture, I'll pick up on that.
Like I said before, you
can use this for anything
that has essentially two
states on a fixed topology.
So like I said, you could use it
for A and B atoms on a lattice.
It's very often used for
surface absorption as well.
If you say you have a surface--
let's say this is a
triangular lattice,
so that could be the
surface sites on a 1 1
1 FCC metal, like
platinum or palladium.
If stuff can absorb
on the lattice side--
now you can really see that
my pen is miscalibrated.
I'm drawing on
the latest points.
So if you want to
know if stuff absorbs,
well, you see that
becomes a binary problem.
At each site you want
to know, is there
an absorbent there or not?
So you can define a binary
variable and whether it's
plus or minus 1 doesn't matter.
People often write things
in not spin variables
but occupation variables,
which are maybe
a little more natural.
They're mathematically
less elegant,
but you could say the
occupation variable is
1 when the side is occupied
and is 0 when the side is not.
The advantage then is that
you only get interaction
when two things are occupied.
So one occupied side
with one occupied side
gives you no contribution
to the Hamiltonian,
because one of the p i's is 0.
Whereas if you use spins,
then this is a plus 1,
and this is minus 1.
So it gives you a contribution
to the Hamiltonian.
Mathematically it all
works out, but it's
a little more confusing.
So you can even write that
out for a binary alloy.
You can sum over the probability
that you have A B bonds on i j
and multiply with
the A B interaction.
You can get the
probability that it's A A
and multiply it with
the AA interaction,
and you get the probability
that it's B B and multiply
with the B B interaction.
OK.
I think the coolest
thing about Monte Carlo
is that you have anomalous
degrees of freedom
about the moves you do.
These are essentially
the perturbations
you attempt to get to the next
state in the Markov chain.
And the one thing
you should never do
is let yourself be guided
there or constrained
by physical principles.
People often do moves that
they think are physical.
But remember, it's not the
point to do a physical move.
The point is to efficiently
sample phase space.
And so on the spin
model, well, you
think, a spin going
from up to down
or vice versa is
a physical move.
Spins flip up and
down all the time.
But in some cases,
for example, it's
much more efficient to flip
over whole patches of spin.
When you're near a second-order
transition in a material,
the fluctuations in the
system are very long range.
So it's sort of like
the wind blowing
to a wheat field or something.
There are whole patches of
spin that move together.
So you'll get much
better convergence there
if you flip whole
patches of spin.
So rather than
attempting one at a time,
you could say I'm going to
attempt 10 at a time close
to each other.
So you can always
pick your dynamic.
So I've given you an example.
Here's an example of
two types of dynamics.
Let's say you have A and
B atoms on a lattice.
So if you want to
equilibrate that,
you could pick the
obvious dynamics.
You could interchange A and
B. So if you have a lot of us
and you have A here and B here,
you could interchange them.
That could be a possible move.
And it's sort of
an obvious move,
because it sort of
mimics diffusion.
Atoms interchange and
equilibrate like that.
That's called Glauber
dynamics on the lattice model.
Turns out that that's useful,
but a much faster move
to equilibrate is
actually exchanging
the identity of the atoms.
So rather than interchanging A
and B at different positions,
you take an atom, and if it's
A, you try to turn it into B.
And if it's B,
you try to turn it
into A. That's called
Kawasaki dynamics.
Now, you see that if you
do Kawasaki dynamics,
you will need some kind
of chemical potential.
Because in Glauber
dynamics, you constrain--
the composition is fixed.
You just interchange the
positions of the A and B,
but you're not changing
the number of A or B.
You conserve the concentration.
In Kawasaki dynamics, you don't
change the number of particles,
but you do change the
concentration of the A and B
species.
Because whenever I flip A to B,
I'm changing the concentration.
So you will need some kind
of chemical potential term
in your Hamiltonian, and
that chemical potential term
is the difference in chemical
potentials of A and B.
So that difference will
drive the concentration.
So it's essentially
multiplied with--
this is essentially
the concentration.
It's the sum of the probability
that you have A on each side.
That's essentially
the concentration.
OK.
You'll find that Kawasaki
dynamics equilibrates 100 times
faster easily in many cases.
The reason is that, if you
think about it, if you started
with a situation where you had
too much A in one area and too
much B in another, if
you do Glauber dynamics,
you can really only
equilibrate that system
by slowly diffusing these.
A has to go this way,
B has to go that way.
In Kawasaki dynamics, the
A here feels right away
that there's too
much of it, and it
starts turning to B. The B
here starts turning to A,
and you're done.
So it tends to be a
much more efficient way.
This is sort of a generic thing.
Open systems tend to equilibrate
faster than closed systems.
So if you can at all
make your system open
and end up with the same end
result, it'll go much faster.
And it's essentially because
you give open systems
more degrees of freedom.
You can change the
chemistry of them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, principally
[INAUDIBLE] complexity
of the system.
First of all, you're
getting [INAUDIBLE]..
GERBRAND CEDER: Not in
the thermodynamic limit.
That's sort of an idea
of statistical mechanics
is that you get
the same averages.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GERBRAND CEDER: You can.
But but you still--
so that'll definitely
make it go faster
if you do random exchanges,
but you still lose efficiency.
I'll tell you why.
First of all, you have to
pick a dissimilar pair.
So if you think about
it, half of the time
you'll pick a similar pair.
So you will pick
A here and A here,
and so you have to
give up on that move,
because it's not
going to do anything.
So that's one thing.
That's not a major thing.
But the fact that you can
fluctuate the concentration
of your system
will in many cases
still allow you to
equilibrate faster.
OK.
And usually this is not--
it's a good thing
you pointed it out,
because I haven't
talked about it.
The choice of the
ensemble should not
matter for thermodynamic
properties.
So any time you're
doing something
with periodic
boundary conditions
and your objective is to
study the bulk of something,
you're OK.
When you go to finite systems--
you're studying, I don't
know, the thermodynamics
of nanoparticles-- then
the ensembles do matter.
The problem that
you run into there
is that it's not obvious
what the right ensemble is.
Like if you study a
nanoparticle, now you have to--
there is essentially
no thermodynamic limit
of a nanoparticle.
It's a finite system
by definition.
And you just have to
sort of figure out,
can it exchange things within
the environment or not.
But in general, the choice of
the ensemble doesn't matter.
Let me sort of skip this.
I've given you examples on
a lattice model right now.
But you can, of course, do
off-lattice Monte Carlo.
For example, this the
example of a liquid.
Let's say a liquid is a
bunch of atoms in a box.
And again you could study the
electrodynamics and track them.
You could also get their
thermodynamic averages
just by sampling all
the possible positions
of the atoms.
So which perturbations
would you pick?
Again, anything that's
consistent with the degrees
of freedom of your
ensemble is fine.
So here an obvious way to do
this would be pick an atom
and you then pick a random
displacement vector.
So you say, I'm going to pick
a random displacement vector,
and that's my perturbation.
I calculate the energy,
it goes down, I accept.
If it doesn't, I
don't accept it.
OK.
The question is, do you truly
pick this displacement vector
random?
But what about its magnitude?
You probably pick its
orientation random,
but what about its magnitude?
Do you pick it out of
the whole box length?
a very small length?
So typically you'll
do it somehow,
like you pick a delta
x-coordinate out of range--
call it minus a over
2 to plus a over 2,
and then the same
for a delta y and z--
and then you randomly
pick a coordinate
in that range for x, y, and z.
But the question is,
what do you take A?
If you take A really
big, you're not
going to accept a lot
of your perturbations.
Because if you take A of
the order of the box length,
then many times if
this is a dense liquid
your atoms is going
to end up very much
on top of something else.
The density of liquids is what?
In many cases, 10%
less than a solid.
At best they're still dense.
So most space is
filled by atoms.
So if you take A
very big, you're
going to sort of
equilibrate in principle
the composition easily--
I mean the density--
but you're not going to
accept a lot of your moves.
So you say, well then, the
solution is I pick A small.
But if you pick A too small,
then you're probably going--
you have a high acceptance rate.
So if you just displace A--
if A is like 100 of an
Angstrom, then you're
atom is just moving
a very little bit.
So most time, you're
going to accept it.
But what's the problem now
is you have high degree
of correlation in your average.
Essentially all the states
you put in your Markov chain
look all the same.
If you barely this place your
atom, they all look the same.
So it's going to take a really
long time to get good averages.
Actually, you could almost
think of Monte Carlo with very
small perturbations
on the system,
it's almost like
molecular dynamics.
It's like the atoms
sort of move slowly
with a kind of random
force, but they still
move slowly along trajectories
and are real trajectories,
but they don't wildly
go through phase space.
The nice thing about
models like this
is that you can actually,
during the simulation, adjust A.
And this is often what's done.
Often people will adjust
it so that they get
a reasonable acceptance rate.
If you set A too big, then
you get low acceptance rate.
If you set A too small, you get
a high acceptance rate people.
Typically shoot for
anywhere from 0.3
to 0.5 acceptance rate.
So you want to be somewhere
where the order of a 1/3 to 1/2
of the moves you
try are accepted.
Because if they
don't get accepted,
you're wasting all your
effort calculating energies.
And this depends a
little bit on the cost
of your energy function.
If you're doing this
with quantum mechanics,
then you really want to
optimize your Monte Carlo moves,
because any energy evaluation
costs you a lot of time.
If you're doing this with
maybe some simple hard sphere
model or something, you can
afford to have a lot of moves--
calculate a lot of energies
on which you don't execute.
So the last thing
I want to say is,
how do you pick random numbers?
How do you implement
probabilities?
Because it's sort of not
obvious in a computer.
Computers are not probabilistic.
And that's done by
random number generation.
Sort of maybe obvious, but
I want to show it anyway.
So remember, what
you want to do is
you want to implement a move
with a given probability
with this Boltzmann factor.
Remember, if delta
E is positive,
that Boltzmann factor
is between 0 and 1.
So let's say this is the value.
Well, what you do is you pick
random numbers between 0 and 1.
And what's the probability
that the random number
is less than this exponential?
Well, that probability is that
exponential of minus beta E i.
We'll call this p i.
If you take a random
number and the probability
that that random number
is below p i is p i.
So you pick the random number
if it's below that exponential.
You execute.
If it's above that
exponential, you don't execute.
So you execute now with
the correct probability.
So random numbers give you a way
of implementing probabilities.
There's a few caveats.
A lot of cheap random
number generators
are not at all random.
I used to not believe
this until I tried it.
I always thought that was kind
of like people write books
and they just talk about
it because it's kind
of cool to say how non-random.
They actually are
very non-random.
You will often find
that if you plot
the density of random
numbers you generate,
that there are
discrete holes where
you have very little coverage.
And it's because of the sort
of fractional algorithms
by which they work.
In many cases, that
really doesn't matter.
For a lot of practical
things, it doesn't matter.
I'll tell you where
I've seen it matter.
It matters when you're in this
regime here, really close to 0.
Because essentially,
a random number
generator, the way it generates
random numbers between 0
and 1--
it doesn't do it
between 0 and 1.
It generates between 0--
or is it-- between 0 or 1.
No, between 1 and some integer.
No, sorry, between 0 and
some maximum integer, like 2
to the 16 or
something like that.
And then it divides by 2 to 16.
And that's how you get
it between 0 and 1.
But that means your
set is discretized.
So often what's important
is the spacing between 0
and the smallest random number.
Because if you work
with very high energy
barriers, very high
energy excitations,
they fall in that first gap.
And so you have a completely
discretized probability there.
And there are problems.
It's the kind of thing I
thought I'd never run into,
and I've actually run
into several times
within that
[INAUDIBLE] research.
If your system is
stuck and it doesn't
have a lot of low
energy excitations left,
it tends to execute high
energy excitations with a way
too higher probability.
Because think about it--
if the biggest number
is 2 to the 16th,
your random number hits 0
with a probability of 1 over 2
to the 16th.
That's way too high.
It should be 1 over infinity.
You should hit 0 with a
rate of 1 over infinity
if you had a perfect
continue of random numbers,
but you hit 0 with a
rate 1 over 2 to the 16.
That means if you hit
that random number you
execute any move, even
if it's 100 electronvolt
above the ground state.
Because that
exponential is not 0.
It's small, but it's not
0, So you will execute.
And you'd be surprised how
often this is a problem,
especially if you
have a wild phase
space in which you can go.
So how do you solve this?
We solve it in a trivial way.
We add a small epsilon
to a random number.
Which is so, trivial but
you have to know it I.
I've never seen this
in books actually.
But see you should not hit 0.
Because when you hit 0,
you execute everything.
OK.
So I'm going to stop here.
And let's see, today's Thursday.
So yeah, I'll see you on Tuesday
for the rest of Monte Carlo.